ted
monday officially marks the start of a
brand new school year for clark county
school district students teachers have
already reported back to the classroom
while the district is working to fill
about 2 100 staffing positions the
school year runs through may 22nd of
next year
so because of that we have a very
special cool at school story tonight for
parents as nate tannenbaum explains
getting to the first bell in one piece
is the most important part of the day
taryn breen from the road equity
alliance project wants to cut down on
the crazy traffic crowding of so many
kids getting dropped off at the same
time the less congestion around the
school the safer every child is she adds
not living within walking distance could
be a blessing in disguise if parents
would even park two or three blocks away
and walk their children in from there
what a big difference it would make the
bonuses you get to spend extra time with
your kid and how could that be bad
drivers can't let their guard down once
they're away from any flashing lights in
the immediate vicinity of any campus in
fact brain urges extra attention when
there might be kids on streets near
schools now you've got them crossing 45
mile an hour traffic instead of 25 mile
an hour traffic so you got to pay
attention to those school crossing zones
as much as the actual school zone and
aaron suggests that while the
sentimental urge may be strong as you
send your kid off
maybe try being a little bit of a nag
instead in place of saying i love you as
you leave the house in the morning
remind them put your seatbelt on
make eye contact with drivers where's
your bike helmet just that that one
final thing that could literally save
their life
we will of course have back to school
coverage all day monday here on eight
news now and of course on our website
eightnewsnow.com and if you know
something that's cool at school
let us know cool at school is under the
community tab on our website or email us
coolant school at 8newsnow.com